[Dr. Wilson] So let's now start talking about what is the deep web.
Because your web server can say a few things.
As well as saying "here's your page"
it can also say "I don't know what that page is."
So if I say...
Can we go to "nottingham.ac.uk/freeStuffForMax"?
It goes: I'm sorry I don't know what that is.
Page not found. We don't have "free stuff for max".
It can also say you're not allowed to
go there.
So it can say if I want to go to
"nottingham.ac.uk/hr/increaseMySalary.html"
It will say "sorry you can't go there" that's a bit of the web you're not allowed to see and
that's really what the Deep Web is is
bits of the web that google is not to
see or can't find or hasn't found and so
the easiest way of looking at the Deep
Web is it's just a huge portion of the
web which google doesn't have the
password to go and see your hasn't come
across yet or is sitting unconnected to
the rest of web somewhere
there's four bits
of what makes the deep web or four nice
examples, let's say, of what makes the
Deep Web different from the web
one is that stuff behind passwords so
any place that you go we have to type in
the password is a place that Google can
coax it doesn't have your password so it
it can't look at your bank information, it can't look at your profile page on amazon.co.uk
and in fact if you make your profile on
facebook not public
you essentially pulled your profile on
facebook down into the deep web rather
than having it on the surface bit of the
web and but all the normal pages like
the main page of facebook.com is on
the normal web the surface web that google
can see it just simply can't get X it
doesn't have to probe the password that
you have
there's also lots of dynamic content so
this is the second part content which
gets generated based on what you do or
where you are is that
and so if you go on to amazon.co.uk
and search for something Google hasn't
seen that search results because it
hasn't typed in every single possible
word you could ever type into amazon search
so you see the products. It's found most
of the products, so it's indexed all those
pages because it has links to on the
front page of amazon but it hasn't seen
all the dynamic things that you create
because you typed in a word that it had
thought typing in and so this is dynamic
content that it can't access and so your
facebook feed is another type of dynamic
content which is always changing and so
it's A) it can't get there because it doesn't have the
password and B) the last time i looked
it was different to the time you just
looked so hasn't seen it
there's also something called the robot
exclusion standard which is a nice thing
that's most websites have a little file
which is robots.txt on the server and
that says to google or other things are
browsing automatically you can look at
those pages but please don't look at
those pages and Google simply just
doesn't look at them because it was asked not to.
So there's large portions that the
website designers say please don't index
this but you can look at that
[Brady] Does that just rely on trust though
[Dr Wilson] Yes. Yeah, so you could write a spider that
works like Google spider which just
ignores robots.txt but you'd be somewhat
breaking the rules by doing that. Um...
[Brady] Is that a legal thing, or just...?
[Dr Wilson] I don't know is the fair answer
It could be... it
could just be a politeness thing just like
most standards on the internet.
And so then the four type of stuff
that's in the Deep Web is just stuff
that nobody's ever linked to it, so it's never
been found as this google spiders have
never followed a link to find it and
therefore it's just it's there but
Google hasn't seen it so it's not that
it's hard to access is just so deep that
nobody's found it
so my laptop has a web server on it HTTP
server and so i can host web files on my
laptop and when I connected it to the
Internet
it got a unique address and so people
can type in that address and then see the
web pages that are on my laptop and so
technically kind of anybody could do
that and then you just tell your friends
the unique kind of code for how to get
there.
Not the web link because you didn't create
web link maybe and your friends type in
the 1.128.193.274, go look
at your laptop and then never tell
anybody else about it because your
little secret web page for you and your
friends and so that's just a part of the
web that Google never came across and it
won't come across it until either you
tell Google about it or someone links to
it from another web page that Google's seen.
And so all this is deep web stuff and
which is perfectly normal stuff that Google just doesn't have access to or
hasn't found and so that's the best way
to look at the Deep Web is just all the
parts of the web that Google can't just
walk up and see, or hasn't come and
visited yet. So how big is the Deep
Web is an interesting question
Google's index for the normal web or surface web went past
1 trillion pages not too long ago
that was a kind of milestone it went
past
so Google knows about one trillion pages
but latest estimates of the Deep Web
that it's ninety-five percent whereas
the five percent that google has seen is
there's one trillion pages so it's much much
bigger 500 times bigger and that
sort of makes sense because ninety five
percent of facebook is stuff you look at
after you've logged in with your
password so and there's only a small
portion that Google can see which is
before you log in and and there's whole
websites which you just need a password
to access forums or academic literature
or just huge resources of content that
google doesn't go and see
and so it's very very big it's just not
very scary and not very unusual
it's just behind passwords. So this takes
us then towards the dark web
because we now know what the internet is
and the physical connections we got the
web is which is just software for
transferring information and we know the
Deep Web is which is just the bits as
the web we have seen so what is the dark
web
so the best way to look at the dark web
is that it's just the web but built
differently so it's not surprising
really and then the web was just some
software that someone built in this
describes how people share information
and so you could rebuild that and put it
so saying get that page you could have
built it to say send me that page
you know it's just asked a different
question use a different code speaking
it's like a different language and so
there are several dark webs on the
internet they sit on the internet and
overlay the same internet like the
web does
they just talk different languages they
have secret handshakes and and they
encrypt things in different ways and
they store websites in different places
and you have to look at you have to go
somewhere else to find out where it is
and so a good example of a dark web is
tour which is the onion where they call
it then you go to . onion pages rather
than . com pages
you know it's just different language
different codes and they the way you
asked for a page is differently so ever
where you might have in to Chrome and
say I'd like to see that page about
horses which is on the dark web and the
dark web goes or would you can get page
about horses
that's not how we do things here so you
kind of have to say the panda has orange
shoes and then suddenly gives you that
page about horses that you wanted the
interest is just talking a different
language is essentially transferring
pages of information like the web does
you just have to ask it the right way so
does not mean that all the people who've
got websites out there would have to
rebuild their website as an onion type
we're only if you want to be only on the
onion whip and so you can be browsing
the interweb using Tor which is the
onion browser and that we can look
perfectly well a normal web pages you
can go to Google on it but it also knows
how to or where to find out where the
onion physical computers are and then it
knows how to ask for it and and it's the
other thing it does there was something
is it sends you on a secret strange and
unusual route through the internet to
get there
so if you look at google.com on Tor but
when i did this morning it was in German
because the last place that I came out
on the strange the route was in the
computer somewhere in Germany and this
is sort of why they call it the onion
web because it has many layers that you
go through
so when it asks to view a web page it
wraps up that request into several
layers of encryption and then send it to
the first computer which unlocks the
first layer and says okay thanks now i
know where to go for the second one goes
to a computer in Australia and says
unwrap the next layer and then it goes
to a computer German accent and that one
asks my google have come to see it and
then it kind of gets wrapped back up
again comes all the way back to you and
which is why they call it the onion and
web for the onion browser
it sounds like a kind of huge game of
pass the parcel mixed in with one of
those old nineteen eighties films where
somebody's trying to trace that
complicated really clear phone call or
something
I'm gonna bounce just call through nine
different relay stations throughout the
world and our two satellites this
designed to be more anonymous and more
private and what you're doing so it's
also a bit like a secret spy who's kind
of got into a building suddenly and
taking off his coat and hat he's wearing
an apron and then walks into the kitchen
and seems perfectly normal in there and
then as you get out the back of the
kitchen he takes off the apron is in
overalls and then suddenly drops down
into the sewer and he kind of goes along
a bit in there is a overall is looking
like a sewer here and then pops up the
top takes off his overalls in a perfect
suit ready to go for a meeting somewhere
to get a package and then has to do the
reverse to get back in
so it protects you and anonymity by
encrypting everything and lots of layers
sending in an unusual routes that you
would normally expect and then avoids
being sort of seen on the
more servers and then on the way and by
doing that
so yeah so basically that's why I into
your analogy that come interact with
just the normal world or you can talk to
the spies is that a good way of thinking
of it
yeah it's it can do either the secret
stuff that's on Tor. I can do the normal
stuff that's on the normal web and so
people have to say all the dark web
that's the place where bad things happen
and that's not what it's designed for
the fact that it's anonymous means that
bad things can happen on it more easily
but you can do good things on it when
you have more anonymity so it's slightly
safer perhaps to go and do your online
banking in a public cafe
if you encrypted first and there is a
HTTPS which is secure HTTP and that's
one way of making more secure but then
you can also wrap it and onion layers
and send often so suddenly you're sort
of more safe in a public place and doing
something that you want to do more
privately
so is it dangerous is a question of what
use your anonymity for rather than that
it's specifically designed for dangerous
things because people anonymous they can
do things which are less legal perhaps. I
don't know there's some known flaw of
the onion web and there's ways of
tracking what happens if you carefully
synchronize events that happened the
different stages and you can also if you
view things like Flash over the Tor
browser that breaks all the ideas of it
because it's this built-in different way
so when you login to tourists and to say
don't use Flash because that will give
away your location but if you do this
normal stuff that will be fine, and but
there are people who use it to put on
pages so those things like the silkroad
which is people knew about which is a
place where people could sell and buy
drugs because and you were more
anonymous so that people could host the
website more honest me and all the
people could go and visit in on
anonymously. So it's illegal activity
that's been facilitated by anonymity
there's lots of positive things that
could be facilitated by anonymity so
people who are in an oppressive areas
can browse the web or anonymously
they can communicate with people more
honestly and so on
so let's bring it all back together and
talk about the difference in the Deep
Web the dark web the web and so on so
and the Deep Web was just an area which
is fairly normal of the web or just
behind passwords or does not found and
the dark web is a part of the deep work
for us it's a different copy of the web
really which specifically tries to hide
itself was talking secret code is
wearing camouflage and its hiding as
much as it can be different and to be out of
the way away from google and so then
just makes it private
so the physical internet of computers is
kind of physical connections or
computers together that have IP
addresses each one of those physical
computers can have a web server on it so
that it can talk in software and share
information and pages and so this is the
web
the Deep Web is just part of it which
people can't get too easily and then the
dark web is like a copy of the web that
talks in just the different ways
different languages
start with the basics of the weapon
internet and because most people confuse
those as well as confusing the Deep Web
in the dark where and how the different
and we're just going to try and figure
all that out today